thank you very much tim i fear that i'm
the medicine after the spoonful of sugar
this morning
but before we launch into the details
let me give you a brief overview of what
i'm aiming for
i'm going to tell you about scar slimmer
and the title i gave to the two sessions
was
scarf lemma and applications and the
applications are all to matching
and there are two reasons for this
reason number one is matching is a
subject of great current interest
among economic theorists and second
matching is a subject that has attracted
the attention of computer scientists
and economic theorists and operations
researchers for at least
50 years if anything is an example of a
successful collaboration
it is the study of matching and what is
interesting about this collaboration
is that it has not been done through
individuals working together
but simply people reading each other's
papers
there are two threads in the literature
on matching
the first thread i'm going to call
cardinal which is concerned with the
problem of finding a matching
that maximizes some function so maximize
a weighted sum of edges
that form a matching this problem in
economics is known as the shapley-shubik
assignment game
or assignment model and in computer
science it's of course the bipartite
matching problem
okay as i said this has a long history
some of you will recall
that harold kuhn who had an algorithm
called the hungarian algorithm
which he would be the first to admit
that he was unfortunately anticipated by
seidel a century earlier
subsequently dimash gail and sotomayor
showed that the hungarian algorithm for
the assignment model
actually terminated in the minimal
valuation prices
and the minimal valuation prices were
actually the victory prices for that
particular economic environment
more recently in economics uh the
the goliath edmunds decomposition
theorem for matching has proved useful
in the study
of kidney matching so there's one thread
in the matching
literature where you see ideas from one
subject
being moved over into the other now the
other thread in matching theory i'm
going to call
ordinal matching that begins with gail
and shapley
there the goal again is to find a
matching but not a matching that
optimizes some function
of the edges rather you are looking for
a matching
that is in some sense not dominated
by any other matching now
the two threads have developed almost
independently of each other
but nevertheless you see many parallel
results
so one of the things i want to convey to
you is you should not be surprised
by this the moment you understand scar
slimmer
scar slimmer in some sense gives us an
explanation
for why we should see roughly the same
results
in both the cardinal and the ordinal
matching literature
the second message i want to get across
is that scarf's lemma provides a
different way to look at matching
problems
that i think is fruitful in the sense
that it suggests
interesting directions that have not
been pursued so far
so those are the two messages that i
want to convey both today and tomorrow
so i'm going to begin first with the
statement of scarce lemma
and the statement i'm going to give you
is not the version that appears
in his published paper it's a version
that appears in an
unpublished paper and the first time i
learned about this particular
interpretation or rendering
of scarce lemma was
in a paper by kerali and pop okay
so here is uh here is the essence of the
lemma
you have a non-negative matrix and a
vector of right-hand sides
and every component of the vector of
right-hand sides
is strictly positive and you have a
polyhedron
here's the polyhedron now comes the
peculiar part
every row of the matrix
has a strict preference ordering over
the non-zero
entries in that row
if you want you can imagine every entry
of the a matrix is positive
in which case every row has a strict
ordering over the columns
now why on earth such a such a feature
should be interesting
is not clear at first glance but bear
with me now
a feasible vector x in the polyhedron
dominates a column if the following is
true
there is a binding constraint i
okay that
column has a non-zero intersection with
that row
and if you ask that row that row prefers
every column that intersects it
and has positive weight in x to
column r so in terms of a picture
here's the matrix a
here are the components of the vector x1
x2 up to xn
here is a row i
here is xr so xr
has a non-zero entry here in this row
if you look at all the other non-zero
entries in that row
that have positive weight
in x that row prefers
every one of these to this one
okay let me pause here for questions
yes there's only one such one of these
uh so now so you fix an x
okay that vector x dominates column
r there's only one r right okay
now what you can do is you can ask is
there a vector x that dominates
every column r so can you find a
feasible
x that dominates every single column
you just said there's only one such
column no
here i'm defining dominating a single
column
right this is the definition of x
dominating column r
now i can ask does there exist an x that
dominates
every column oh i see r
is not necessarily positive in x xr is
not
greater than zero yes
xr could be zero i'm not saying xr is
positive
or or or not just pick any column r
and domination should say that you
should prefer everything that achieves
positive weight
to column r strictly strictly
and if column r gets positive weight
then it's different
and this is i for different columns
probably i'm guessing i'm sorry yes so
for every column r there exists an i
okay right but uh so if x is the old
zero vector
yes uh then uh
if x is the okay uh i can kill that by
requiring this to be equal to
okay the reason why i didn't bother
about it is because uh
here is scarf's lemma every such
polyhedron
has an extreme point that dominates
every column of a
doesn't be positive
can be yes every component of b is
strictly positive
so that's exactly so x can't be a zero
yeah x can't be the zero vector yeah
no but that's as i said if you want set
it equal to and that immediately kills
the concern with zero
yes is there like some special case like
for example if a
is uh zero one matrix i'm going to give
you an example in a moment
um as i said as stated it is not clear
that this is relevant for anything in
particular
okay so um
okay so to make sense of what's going on
here it's useful to look at an example
but before i do the example here's a way
that you can anticipate what's going on
think of each row of a as being
associated with some agent
and each column of a represents a
coalition of agents engaged in some
activity
and the entry aij represents in some
sense the contribution of agent i
to activity j
and then this ordering you can interpret
as a preference ordering of the
agent over the different coalitions
it could belong to as well as the levels
of activities
that it would be associated with okay
so let me give you an example and the
example i'm going to give you
is the proof of the existence of a
stable matching
in the sense of gale and shapley so
we have a complete bipartite graph
here are the two sets of vertices that
i'm going to call
doctors and hospitals and each hospital
has a capacity of one
so every hospital can admit only one
doctor
i'll assume that all edges are present
and i will assume that you have the same
number of doctors as you do hospitals
this is without loss of generality by
adding dummy doctors and dummy hospitals
for any vertex v now what's a vertex a
vertex is either a
individual doctor or a hospital
delta of v is the subset of edges
incident to vertex v
and every vertex has a strict ordering
over the edges that are incident to it
but since this is a bipartite graph if
i'm a doctor
and this is one of my incident edges
that incident edge
goes to a particular hospital so a
preference
ordering over my incident edges is also
a preference
ordering over the hospitals and the same
is true for each hospital
okay
now what are we interested in we're
interested in a matching that has a
certain property
so let me first describe matchings
introduce a variable
x sub e is one if you select the edge
what is an
edge an edge is a doctor hospital pair
and zero otherwise and
the convex hull of all feasible
matchings we know is given by this
so you can either invoke the burkhoff
von neumann theorem
or you can invoke total unimodularity of
this constraint matrix
this is getting to your example event
okay
so what does this constraint say the set
of the number of edges that i pick that
are incident to vertex v
is at most one so every doctor is
matched to at most one hospital
every hospital is matched to at most one
doctor
now a matching is blocked by a pair
dh if first of all you didn't match that
pair
and if you look at dr d
dr d is currently matched to h prime
dr d would prefer hospital h
and if you look at hospital h it is
currently matched to dr d
prime hospital h would prefer dr d
so in other words this pair is a
blocking pair
if each of them by breaking the matching
that you have assigned them
could do better both of them must do
strictly better
now the idea of blocking here is
capturing the following notion
that agents can vote with their feet you
can dictate a matching
but you cannot force agents to accept
the matching
and the way we're modeling that idea
that they cannot that you cannot force
them to accept a matching
is through the notion of blocking so any
matching you propose
must have the feature that it cannot be
blocked a matching is called stable
if it cannot be blocked by any pair
now it is not immediately obvious that
stable matchings exist
the other thing i'd like you to notice
is that this is not an optimization
notion
stability is not obtained by maximizing
some function of the edges this is an
ordinal notion of matching
now there's a remarkable result of galen
shapley that gives us a very simple
algorithm
to find a stable matching always so they
always exist
and what's more more than one of these
can exist
everyone with me so far so i'm going to
use scarf's lemma to show you the
existence of a stable matching
here's the polyhedron that describes all
matchings
so this is the a matrix that's the right
hand sides of b's
everything is strictly positive the
coefficients of the a matrix are either
0
or 1. so the first condition in scarf's
lemma is met
every row of this ax less than or equal
to b matrix
corresponds to either a doctor or a
hospital
every doctor or hospital has a strict
ordering over the edges
but edges correspond to variables which
correspond to columns of the a matrix
so every row of my a matrix here
has a strict ordering over the columns
that intersect it
now what does it mean for a vector
x that satisfy this satisfies this to
dominate a column
well here it is let's boil this down to
the case of matchings
for every edge e for every column
there exists a row a row in our case is
a vertex
which is either doctor or hospital
that edge must be incident to a vertex
so there exists a vertex
in which positive weight is assigned to
everything
at the same rank as e or higher
binding constraint now what do we know
about the bipartite
matching problem every one of its
extreme points is integral
scaffs lemma says there exists a
dominating extreme point
so therefore there exists a matching
this is all
zero one so in particular
if edge e were not chosen by your
matching
that would be zero and what would that
say
it would say that vertex v is matched to
at least one edge
that it prefers to edge e
so air g cannot be part of a blocking
pair
so there exists a vertex v i didn't
specify whether it was doctor or
hospital
but if you want take it to be doctor or
hospital yes
so what does this say in non-bipartisan
matching
next few
is this slides
we read each other's minds
okay
now um no algorithm
just existence okay
what is this particular example
it does give you an algorithm you may
not like the algorithm is it different
is it different it will be different and
i'll and i'll get to that in a moment
also
i go back to scarce lemma in a sense
what scarce lemma tells us
is the following every property of an
extreme point of this polyhedron
is inherited by the dominating extreme
point
that's the connection between cardinal
and ordinal matching
every property of the extreme point of
your polyhedron
must be inherited by the dominating
extreme point
right any property that is true of your
extreme point has to be true of the
dominating extreme point
just because it's a subclass just
because it's a subclass that's exactly
right okay
but it's that observation that then
allows us to say something about the
non-bipartite case
which i'll get to in a moment okay okay
non-bipartite case so the non-bipartite
case is called the stable roommates
so now i simply have a set of vertices
i have a set of edges and again
delta v is the set of edges incident to
vertex v
and every vertex has a strict ordering
over the incident edges
but once again every edge links to
another vertex
so a strict ordering over the edges is a
strict ordering over the other
individuals in the economy
so people can be linked to more than one
person
but so you can have multiple ed so i
have an er so for every possible pair
that could be matched
i insert an edge but you will only be
matched to one other person
okay
so again let x equal one if we select a
g and 0
otherwise the integer points of this
polyhedron
will correspond to matchings now notice
i did not say that the extreme points of
this polyhedron are integral
that's not true that's only true for the
bipartite case
okay but what do we know well
um let me finish let me complete
by saying what we mean by stability here
it's the same idea
fix a matching now look at an edge that
is not in your matching
xc is zero this edge forms a blocking
pair
if the members of that pair would prefer
to be with each other
than who you have assigned them to so
it's exactly the same definition
if you notice the notation has not
changed at all
the only thing that has changed is the
polyhedron
well what do we know about the extreme
points of this polyhedron
all theorem of balinskis and
independently nemhauser and trotta
every extreme point of this polyhedron
is half fractional
so every variable is either zero one or
a half
what else do we know if a variable takes
a value of half in one extreme point
it takes the value of a half in every
extreme point
what else do we know about this
polyhedron the variables that have the
value of a half
lie on odd cycles
now here is where i'm using properties
of the extreme point
that are going to allow me to say
something about the nature of the stable
roommates problem
okay let me define what's called a
stable partition
it's a subset of edges every component
of that subset of edges is either a
single edge
or an odd cycle
each cycle has the following property
so a picture may be better than what you
have here
so v1 prefers e2
to e1 so v1 prefers this edge
to this edge in other words mr one
prefers mr two
to mr three
mr two prefers edge three to edge two
so mr two prefers this edge to this one
in other words mr two prefers mr three
to mr one
and then finally over here mr three
prefers mr one to mr two
for those of you familiar with the
stable roommates problem this is the
smallest counter example to the
existence of a stable roommate solution
this cyclic preferences okay
i'm going to call this an odd preference
cycle
and finally what do i need uh for a
stable partition
for every edge that is not part of the
partition
there exists a vertex covered by the
partition
that is incident to a g and that vertex
is incident to an edge that it prefers
to e
so every vertex is covered by an edge in
the stable partition
that it prefers to any edge not in the
partition
scarce lemma stable partitions exist
every extreme point is zero one half
the variables of a half lie on odd
cycles
and then everything else comes from the
domination condition
now we can now ask what's special about
the variables that take the value half
well the variables that take the value
half
lie precisely on these odd preference
cycles
why is that let's look at this
if this has value half then there must
be an
edge that vertex v prefers to edge e
that also has value half so i've got one
edge with value half
and point it toward pointed in the
direction that uh
so i've got edge e
and edge and vertex v
prefers uh okay so here's our g here's
edge f sorry half half
but if this has value a half again
by the dominating condition there must
be another edge coming out with
value a half call that g
but the variables with value of half can
only lie on odd cycles
but those odd cycles have to precisely
be
odd preference cycles by the domination
condition
so we now have a classical theorem of
towns
stable roommate solutions exist if and
only if there are no odd preference
cycles
so two important results in stable
matching and we haven't even broken a
sweat yet
everyone with me so far
okay so this is what i meant earlier by
because you inherit the properties of
the extreme point of that polyhedron
if that polyhedron has very nice
properties you can exploit those
properties and thinking about stability
yes
within the subset condition to make the
vertices matchings actually
uh ah okay very good so one of the
things i didn't mention
in the history of sort of the
connections between computer science
and economics and the study of matching
the version you're now asking for is
sort of hyper graph matching
right i want to put in the condition
that
on an off spot subset of two k plus one
nodes only two k
just get matched which makes the
vertices very good so
um you can write down such a theorem in
this case you do not need to impose the
odd cycle constraint
on every odd cycle you only need to
impose it
on the odd preference cycles then the
theorem you get
is that if that has an integer solution
a stable roommate
solution exists and if it uh if it
doesn't then there is no
stable roommate
that's guaranteed to have matching all
the matching says it's as its vertices
yes
now i understand the question
you want to add in extra constraints
exactly okay
now remember scarf slimmer requires that
every constraint
have an ordering over the columns in it
so if you try to add in extra
constraints
what's the natural ordering to impose
okay
but it's a good question to ask because
i think this uh because i i think in
some sense
if i think about open questions which
i'll talk about tomorrow that scarce
lemma raises
one of these is is i think scarf lemma
provides a useful way to think about
matching with side constraints
if you can be imaginative about how to
choose the preference orderings
over the side constraints and there are
some instances that my co-author tan
win and myself we think we can do so we
can think of some simple examples where
it's whether
it's easy to do the challenge now is are
there more interesting examples where
this can be done
okay now if you ever take a class in
matching in an economics department
you will run through stable matchings
maybe stable roommates
and there's a separate class of problems
which are sometimes called house
allocation problems
the most famous of these is the house
allocation problem
of i think the original paper is scarf
shapley
with a beautiful algorithm due to david
gale known as the top trading cycle
here is the problem every agent owns a
home
every agent has a strict preference
ordering over the homes
including yep over others
is there a way to assign homes to agents
in such a way that no subset of agents
by walking away and trading among
themselves
can each do strictly better
so as i said there's a beautiful
algorithm of david gales called top
trading
which finds such an allocation and this
is usually treated as being separate
from the stable matching problem
there is a more general version of this
problem which i want to describe
which i'm going to call the kansey
housing model after martin kanzi
so you have a set of agents some of them
own homes
not everyone has to the ones that don't
own a home you can give them a dummy
house
each agent also has some money
and the utility of an agent i for a
monetary amount
y and a house hj is denoted by this
and the only thing you need on this
utility function is
it should be continuous and
non-decreasing in money
holding house fixed
now in the case when there is no money
then you only have utility for house you
have the scarf shapley housing model
in the case where your utility for a
house
and money is the utility of the house
minus
money and you have an unlimited amount
of money
you have the sharply shubik assignment
model
so this captures all of the main housing
models into a single model
and the question one asks is in this
model does a core
exist once again is there an assignment
of homes to agents
and monetary transfers so that no
subsets of it no subset of agents has an
incentive
to block the allocation by walking away
with their endowment
and trading among themselves existence
follows almost directly from scar
slimmer
so scarf slumber gives you a single
machine to give you existence results
for
all of these problems
okay everyone with me so far
okay i was going to talk about
cooperative games so let me skip that
yes it's the problem you described is it
convex is it solvable
the kings you're housing okay so uh your
this boils down to what's the complexity
of finding the dominating extreme point
in scott's lemma
oh right so it's as hard as that yes
it's as hard as that
right yes okay yes okay
so you could now ask what is the
complexity of finding the dominating
extreme point
it's p-pad complete now i know that
computer scientists are frequently
nervous about computing
economists are not so i urge you to be
fearless so there are two things i would
say here one
the stable matching problem tells you
that there must be instances of scarf's
lemma
where finding the dominating extreme
point can be done in polynomial time
natural question what other instances
are there
okay second even though it is p-pad
complete
um peter biro and
i think it's gus field or irving and
glasgow
have actually run uh have actually run
scarf slummer for stable matching
problems with couples
that i'm going to describe in a moment
and they claim uh on their
on their test problems now everything is
going to depend on what you think their
test problems are like
that it runs reasonably fast and so they
ran problems on the order of something
like a couple of hundred
and roughly an order magnitude less of
hospitals
and these are not problems that you
necessarily have to run
many times you're just going to run them
once and people are not
waiting with baited breath for the
solutions so i don't think uh for
for for certain reasonable sizes i don't
think the computations are that involved
so the same thing is said about lead
right the same thing is said about lemke
house
right so uh yeah okay now scarf i mean
in a sense you should expect this given
the fact that you can use scarf slimmer
to get all these various existence
results
so for example you know when you'd asked
me the question earlier i'd asked about
hyper
i said hyper graph matching well it
turns out that about roughly 15 years
after scarf
lovash independently rediscovered the
lemma it's in his paper on
normal hyper graphs and the perfect
graph conjecture
so there are actually a number of recent
applications of scarf's lemma in
computer science
so the the one i mentioned by lobash is
an old one a more recent one is by penny
hacksall
in which she models the problem
associated with the bgp
routing protocol as what's known as the
stable paths problem
and then she uses scarf slumber to show
the existence of a stable path
there are other more recent applications
due to thomas fleiner and ronald aharoni
where they use scarf's lemma to show the
existence
establish kernel solvability of certain
hypographs
so it's a very powerful theorem and so
you should expect that it probably has
to be in a much higher complexity class
than you know linear programming for
example okay
okay now what i've done so far
is describe problems to which we knew
there were solutions already
and so scarf's lemma gives us a sort of
direct way
to get those solutions the scoffs lemma
allow us to do anything new
so this is what i want to go to next so
what i want to go to next is now the
stable matching problem
with couples so here's the setup
i have a set of single doctors and a set
of couples of doctors
each couple is denoted by a pair
first female second male this does not
represent my views on marriage this is
simply a convenient way
to specify an ordering you'll see why in
a moment
d star is the list of individual doctors
there is a set of hospitals every single
doctor
is characterized by a strict preference
ordering
over hospitals and the empty set
so the empty set corresponds to being
matched with yourself
in other words not being assigned to any
hospital
right every couple has a strict
preference
ordering over pairs of hospitals
okay so what i want to emphasize about
this is
you're taking the position of not being
a marriage counselor
so each member of the couple may have
their own particular preferences
that is not your concern when they come
to the mechanism
they have to report an ordering over
pairs of hospitals
okay each hospital has a capacity
and the preferences of a hospital are
modeled by a choice function
what is a choice function a choice
function
takes as input a subset of individual
doctors
and outputs a subset of that subset
and the choice function we're going to
use which is standard in the literature
has the property of being responsive and
that's another way of saying there's a
simple algorithmic description of this
choice function
it is this every hospital assigns a
priority ordering strict over individual
doctors
so each doctor by themselves gets a
score
when you give a hospital a subset of
doctors to choose from
it chooses the highest score doctors
up to its capacity
i mean sorry this should be d star thank
you
the set of individual doctors not single
doctors
okay so is it clear what a responsive
choice function is
every individual doctor gets a score if
you give me a subset of doctors to
choose from
i rank order them by the score and i
keep picking until i hit my capacity
constraint
now there is an asymmetry that i want to
draw your attention to
preferences of doctors are described by
preference orderings
preferences by hospitals are described
by choice functions
choice functions are not preference
orderings
every preference ordering gives rise to
a choice function
choose your k most preferred doctors
from the set
but every choice function does not give
rise to a preference ordering
if i just hand you a choice function you
may not be able to recover
an underlying preference ordering
everyone with me on the distinction now
there are two reasons for why you might
want to model hospitals using choice
functions
reason one is high-minded reason number
two is cynical
so let me do the high-minded reason yes
extract the order from the choice
function okay
the problem is that from a choice
function you can you can extract whether
i rank a over b
but if you just know the pairwise
orderings that's not enough to get the
ordering over everything
you might say well what if i choose from
triples but the problem is when i choose
from the triple
you're missing information about one
pair
is that okay you can construct a
preference ordering over subsets of
doctors
no you can't no there's so if i give you
a choice function it need not be
consistent
with uh with a preference ordering over
subsets yes
if your choice function is responsive
because i'm giving you the extra
information
right okay now um
so the high-minded reason is that
hospitals simply maybe
will are simply unable to give you a
preference ordering over subsets of
doctors
because decisions are made by committee
and so perhaps all they can really give
you
is their algorithm for deciding so
that's the high-minded reason
the cynical reason is the following
gail and shapley's deferred acceptance
algorithm
okay so as i told you earlier gail and
shapley established the existence of
stable matchings
with a beautiful algorithm called
deferred acceptance
which william thompson argues cogently
should really be re-labeled
immediate rejection let me remind you of
that how the algorithm works
every doctor points to their favorite
hospital
every hospital that has at least two
doctors pointing to it
rejects all but their most preferred
doctors
rejection is irrevocable i do not get to
revisit
any doctor i have rejected
now think about trying to extend that to
the case of matching not
one doctor but many doctors to a
particular hospital
this is an algorithm that works in
rounds when i reject a doctor in round k
i may not revisit that decision in round
k
plus one in some sense my preferences
have to have some kind of
path independence or memoryless property
in order for such an algorithm to
terminate in a stable matching
so if you are locked into the deferred
acceptance algorithm
and you want to extend the gail and
shapley result
from one to one to one to many matching
then you have to think of choice
functions which have the right
memoryless property
that puts a constraint on the kinds of
choices you can look at
what i want to argue is that scoffs
lemma
does not constrain us in this way
in other words there are examples of
choice functions
that do not have this appropriate path
independence property
for which scaf's lemma will give us the
existence of a stable matching
i'm sorry i missed i missed the punch
line for uh for the for the
hospital for the hospital right so the
right so it is standard in the
literature to model the preference of
hospitals using choice functions
and all of the positive results we have
about many to one matching
impose a very strong condition on the
choice function which amounts to path
independence
problem is interactable it is and i'm
going to describe
and and now i'm going to say why this
problem is interesting precisely because
it's hard
okay i will very good i will give you
the stability condition for what
for what matching means in this case but
what i want to emphasize here
is that scarf's lemma potentially allows
us a way to think about matching
problems
without relying on the usual assumptions
on choice functions
okay okay let me tell you what a stable
matching is in this setting
so i'm going to use the economic
notation rather than the more natural
integer programming notation for the
moment
so a matching is a function that maps
doctors to hospitals
so mu sub h is the subset of doctors
that are matched to hospital h
mu sub s is the position that single
doctor s
receives and mu f c and umc
are the positions that the female and
male member of the couple see obtain
now what does blocking mean the first
condition you want is
individual rationality so
for the for the doctors it basically
means that
whatever you give them should be
preferable to the empty set
for a hospital it means the following if
i
assign this hospital this subset of
doctors
and then i hand them that subset of
doctors and ask them
choose which doctors you want they
should come back and say i want exactly
the subset you handed me
okay now what does blocking mean
so there are three ways that blocking
can occur
the first is the usual way i've
described before with a single doctor
so there is a single doctor that prefers
hospital h
to the hospital that you have assigned
her to and
if that single doctor approaches
hospital h
and says consider me along with the
doctors you have already been assigned
this hospital says i will certainly
choose you
okay now the other wrinkle involves
couples
and it works pretty much the same way
you could have a couple
and two different hospitals
or you could have a couple and two slots
in the same hospital
so this is blocking everyone with me so
far
so the question is can you find a
matching that is stable
in other words a matching that cannot be
blocked
so here's an example to show you that
stable matchings need not exist
what do i want to draw your attention to
in this example
one it's small two hospitals
one couple one single doctor
second each hospital has a capacity of
one
so the distinction between choice
function and preferences
is irrelevant this is a counter example
to both setups
okay now the complexity question given
an instance of a matching problem with
couples
finding if it has a stable matching
that's an np-hard problem
roth and perrinson proposed a
modification of the gail shapley
algorithm
which has the following property in
every recorded instance
of the national resident matching
program it has found a matching that is
stable with respect to reported
preferences
now separately kojima pattak and roth
ashlagi bravaman and hassadim
have attempted to explain why this may
be the case
and this is in a in a probabilistic
model
so preferences are drawn uniformly at
random size of the market goes to
infinity
fractions of couples goes to zero then
the result is
that with probability approaching one
roth and parentson
will terminate in a matching that is
stable
okay you seem puzzled
thinking about one couple one hospital
it's since there's not exist issues even
then
if if um hospital will only hire both of
them but the couple
would rather be unemployed than you know
only one month so
aren't there even just one hospital one
couple counters now
um yeah there might be even smaller
counter examples i decided to give the
first one that i was
aware of in published form okay
uh what else do we know in the u.s the
fraction of couples is as much as 10
percent and the ashlagi
tal paper and ita is here and you can
ask him for more details
shows that if the fraction of couples
does not go to zero
the probability of the algorithm not
terminating in a stable matching is
positive
and simulations by b rowettal show that
when the number of couples is large
roth the roth and parentson algorithm
fails to find a stable match
okay so what i've described now
is a matching problem where it's np hard
to find out even if there is a stable
matching
and second this is if a stable matching
doesn't exist what are you going to do
so here is the theorem
given any instance of a matching problem
with couples
there is a nearby instance that is
guaranteed to have a stable matching
now what does nearby mean for any
capacity vector of your instance
there exists a nearby capacity vector k
prime that has the following properties
hospital by hospital it differs from the
original capacities by at most four
in aggregate the total capacity and on
the k prime is no more than nine
more than the original what's special
about k
prime we will give you a stable matching
with respect to k
prime we do not change preferences
we do change capacities
yes k prime can actually be smaller than
k
yep in fact i'm going to stop here and
let you ask questions
because if you don't find this result
interesting everything else i have to
say is completely irrelevant
yes i have two questions one is
can you find that nearby stable matching
efficiently
second this is obvious for the
particle responsive presences yes
so it's exactly for what i think of as
the standard setup
responsive preferences on the side of
the hospitals
and no restriction on the preferences on
the side of doctors
now we can actually relax the responsive
preference condition and allow a little
bit of complementarity and get the same
result
yes can i ask my question in the
question form
yes do you know anything if i insist
that k prime has to be bigger
bigger or equal to k
we don't but in reflecting upon the
techniques used
we think we in other words i think we
could get you the answer
i don't know the answer and the
computation
uh the complexity okay i i these are not
the questions i was expecting the
question i was expecting was
how do you know these are big numbers or
small numbers
but the complexity is okay
four and nine
they look small they look small
this is not your peacock this is not the
econ audience
okay so yes thomas it seems that
whatever the whatever the input is you
can generate a case where
most of the hospitals have a lot of
hospitals have to change their
capacities this repeat the instance
multiple times
ah hold on okay so you're exactly right
that one should be a little suspicious
initially about this result
because think about the counter example
the non-existence i gave you
why not just duplicate that
non-existence counter example a million
times
right then it would seem that in each
one of those instances you'd have to add
extra capacity
to be able to get a stable matching but
that's not what's happening
right in total we're adding no more than
nine more slots
so what's really happening is we're
shuffling capacity
between hospitals so i may be taking
capacity from one hospital
and giving it to another which is why i
want the freedom over here
to be less than okay now if you're
bothered by that
the thing is i think i asked this from
your co-author
and more convinced more he was more
convinced that you can do it
going efforts only there's a little bit
bigger numbers yeah so if you insist
that i never
i never decreased the capacity of any
individual hospital
you're going to have to pay for it by
having an a larger upper bound here
but i think that was claiming that's a a
number not no n
yeah it's a number it'll be a fixed
constant it will it'll be ants yes
so let me emphasize here nine and four
are completely independent of the size
of the problem
this is not an asymptotic result what's
a typical kh
uh typical kh is probably the smallest
is probably around 20.
um another question you might ask is how
much does
how much does a residency slot cost it's
about a hundred thousand under current
estimates
us government spends on the order of
nine billion on the residency program
so samir cooler suggested that we should
actually title this paper one million
dollars is enough to solve the two body
problem
sorry what's the capacity for the
typical sum of the capacities
so let's see i think if we have about um
that's all the residents yeah all the
roughly all the residents in the u.s so
on the order of about thirty thousand
yes can you improve on the constants 4
and 9.
well the thing you might be you should
be concerned about
is that a perturbation of size 4 could
be very costly for a small program
rather than a big program
right so if that's the case you might
want a smaller bound here
so the answer is if you don't like four
i can give you three
but then you have to give up on this
uh sorry what does it mean to give up on
that you get a bigger constant
i i i don't think we could get i don't
think we can bound this
if you insist that this is less than
three we cannot bound
we cannot bound the aggregate increase
in capacity
you cannot bound it or it's yourself or
it's
there is no bet i think the answer is
there is no
um
no there is no bound that's i think we
can construct an example
where the aggregate capacity could be
arbitrarily large yes
how difficult is it to find the k prime
okay
so um uh i'm looking at the clock
because i want to say stay tuned for
tomorrow
yes so um so let me give you an overview
of what's going to happen
yeah good you're not happy with the
preference model yet
um so if you have responsive preferences
i can still
like prefer to have at most 10 positions
in responsive preferences and then if
you increase my capacity to 12
i might not hire anybody else because i
still prefer to have 10 positions
but notice we never decrease the total
capacity
so if there is excess demand for doctors
we're not burning any slots
so if there's excess demand on the part
of doctors we're not achieving stability
by burning slots
right the trivial way to get stability
is get rid of all slots
right so so we're not doing that
yes
you think you thought you could do this
like even if you demand that
the capacity never decreases yes then
you also said that it works
by not not eliminating your adding
not like eliminating possible but
shuffling around shuffling them around
right so we'd have to add more in the
aggregate
i'm wondering
i wonder what you said earlier about
what happened if you repeat that the
same example
oh so if you repeat the same example a
million million times you might think
that should give us a counter example to
the second bound right
because you might have to add an
additional slot for each counter example
but we're avoiding that by shuffling
capacity between the counter examples
right so you take away capacity from
some hospitals and give it to others
so yeah oh i think that earlier like
you know you can do it without reducing
capacity in
any hospital no reducing aggregate
capacity
right
ah okay so um those
those of you those of you familiar for
example with the early paper say by
tardos and schmoyes
on um on the generalized assignment
problem
where you get a result that says if you
allow us to violate the
you know the budget constraint by a
factor of two then we can get you close
to the original objective function value
that's a multiplicative bound factor of
two i'm going to argue that
multiplicative bounds here
these are hard to interpret i know how
to interpret one two
three doctors because it corresponds to
a tangible monetary amount
one hundred thousand two hundred
thousand three hundred thousand
i can look at the number of doctors and
compare it with the existing capacity of
the hospital
and get a sense of whether that's big or
small multiplicative for me is harder to
interpret in this context
okay but there is nothing to prevent you
from doing this kind of analysis
and focusing on multiplicative bounds
yes
shuffles uh good question no we don't
uh we're currently running simulations
and we would like to do the simu
the simulations presumably would be to
check for two things
is it the large or the small hospitals
that are affected
if it's the small hospitals that are
affected this is bad news for us
right if there are a lot of shuffles
this is also bad news for us
okay but uh this we cannot tell
analytically
simulation yes did i interpret your
comment on like duplicating the same
environment many times correctly
it would seem that that implies that
statement two can be
changed to be the inequality of the
direction with minus nine
so in other words you can do the same
thing but only lowering the total number
of doctors by at least none
uh because if you want to do this you
have to have plus and so
they have to all balance out so if you
actually so if you are willing to accept
a reduction in the total capacity
i think we can give you a smaller number
here not nine but something less
i don't know what that is we didn't do
that because the concern you would have
is if we were reducing capacity you
might then say
oh i see how you're getting stability
you're getting stability by removing
resources
right and uh so we don't want to do that
that does this this duplication thing
would have to then be doing using
analogous
on both the upper and the lower bound
yes
okay the strategic considerations well
so my answer is going to be the
following
the roth and parents and algorithm which
is in use does not have any incentive
compatibility guarantee
so don't hold me to one as well
there is okay so um the
strategic concern you should have here i
think is the following
we're manipulating capacities in the
standard model we're only concerned with
manipulation of preferences
but it had but the question of
manipulating capacities has been
considered
and in the standard gale shapley model
if agents can manipulate capacities
then you cannot get incentive
compatibility so we're manipulating
capacities here so you might
be concerned that hospitals would have
an incentive to misreport their
capacities
because they know when you run the
algorithm the capacities will be
adjusted
afterwards okay i'm not so concerned
about that because hospitals are
required to provide a plan
justifying their capacities
it's not simply a matter of reporting
the capacities
now in terms of the preferences well
i'll give you the outline of the
algorithm and you can decide whether
agents are perspicacious enough to be
able to see how to game it
i don't think so but it doesn't mean
that they should report truthfully
right but notice i said roth and
parentson was stable with respect to
reported preferences
i didn't say with respect to true
preferences
yes happens if you simulate
the capacities
maybe you can show that it doesn't exist
it's really a small measure
um that way so in fact in our
simulations we are varying both
preferences and capacities
well so we don't have the results yet
these are simulations that we're doing
currently
yeah so what this theorem suggests so
this suggests i think another theorem
that maybe take any instance of a stable
matching problem
then with high probability in a small
neighborhood around that instance there
must be an instance which does have a
stable matching
i yeah i don't know yeah i don't know
how to prove that
but i think this is what uh this
suggests okay so uh yes
is there a clear connection between how
preferred the hospitals are and how the
capacities are adjusted
uh no so in the way that we set up the
algorithm we do not favor
one hospital over the other but there
are various places that you could break
ties in a particular way
so that you could break ties so as to
avoid touching the small capacity
hospitals
as late as possible in the algorithm
okay uh let me now now let me in the one
i've run over
here but in one minute let me tell you
what you should expect to see tomorrow
i'm going to set up the problem of
finding a matching as a linear program
so that i can use scarf now here's the
other feature of scarf
scarf gives us a definition of stability
for fractional matchings
i'm going to take the fractional
matching which is the dominant
dominating extreme point in scarf and
i'm going to round it
into an integer solution in such a way
as to preserve stability
now that rounding idea actually goes
back to the shapley folkman style lemma
so the other thing i will tell you about
is the shapley folkman style lemma
and the refinement subsequently in
computer science to that lemma
which give you much stronger bounds than
the original shapley folkman style lemma
does
so i've exceeded my time i apologize for
running over i'll see you all tomorrow